heute habe ich für euch super leckere
sneakers mit cupcakes mit einer leckeren
marshmallow füllung und zwei toppings
für den teig brauchen wir 150 gramm mehl
130 gramm zucker 150 gramm butter 2
zimmer war maier 80 gramm weiße
schokolade eine prise salz 1 teelöffel
vanille extrakt 5 gramm backpulver und
50 bis 100 milliliter milch als erstes
wird die butter mit dem zucker der prise
salz und der vanille drei bis vier
minuten auf höchster stufe hält mich
geschlagen
und jetzt gehen wir noch die zwei eier
dazu
in der zwischenzeit sehen wir schon mal
das meer mit dem backpulver
wenn die eier gut untergerührt sind
kommt die geschmolzene weiße schokolade
in den teig achtet aber bitte darauf
dass sie nur noch zimmer warm ist
als nächstes wird löffelweise die mail
mischung ab wechsel mit der milch dazu
gegeben wie viel milch für einen schönen
geschmeidigen teig braucht hängt von der
größe der eier ab
falls bei eurer küchenmaschine auch die
trockenen zutaten immer am rand haften
bleiben
dann schiebt sie einfach runter und nix
noch mal alles schön durch
das ist jetzt idealerweise die
konsistenz des teigs also der darf nicht
runter fließen aber auch nicht zu fest
sein
der teig wird dann in muffin förmchen
verteilt und im vorgeheizten backofen
bei 180 grad ober unterhitze für 18
minuten gebacken
danach lassen wir sie vollständig
auskühlen für unser erdnussbutter
frosting brauchen wir 250 gramm cremige
erdnussbutter 50 gramm geliebten
puderzucker 200 gramm doppel ram
frischkäse ein bis zwei esslöffel zimmer
warme milch und einen teelöffel vanille
extra für der saane forsting brauchen
wir 250 gramm doppel rahmen frischkäse
300 gramm sahne 50 gramm weiße
schokolade und für die deko 30 us reit
und 150 gramm gesalzene erdnüsse und an
dieser stelle brauchen wir noch fünf
teelöffel sommerbad die ich hier leider
vergessen habe mit aufzuführen
für die füllung benötigen wir 60 gramm
zimmer warme butter 20 gramm besiegten
puderzucker 70 gramm marshmallow 420
gramm handelsübliche karamellsoße und 50
gramm erdnüsse für die blitzschnelle
marshmallow füllung geben wir als erstes
die zimmer waren butter mit dem
puderzucker in die küchenmaschine und
dafür benutzt sie am besten den rühe
haken
und dann kommt das marshmallow flaf
hinzu und zuletzt auch die karamellsoße
und so schnell ist unsere marshmallow
füllung fertig und so sieht die
konsistenz aus für das erdnussbutter
frosting geben wir die erdnussbutter und
den puderzucker in unsere rührschüssel
und vermengen das so lange bis eine
homogene masse entsteht
falls die masse noch zu fest ist könnt
ihr ein bis zwei esslöffel zimmer warme
milch dazugeben
dann kommt das vanille extrakt und zum
schluss der doppel raum frischkäse hinzu
und so sieht jetzt unser fertiges
erdnussbutter forsting aus für das seine
forsting schlagen wir die sahne mit zwei
teelöffeln seiner partei
in einer anderen schlüssel wird der
frischkäse mit drei teelöffeln sommerbad
und der geschmolzenen abgekühlte
schokolade vorbereitet
zu guter letzt wird jetzt noch die sahne
untergehoben und fertig ist das seine
forsting
für die dekoration werden 150 gramm
erdnüsse grob gemahlen wer kein mixa hat
kann die erdnüsse auch in einen
gefrierbeutel tun und dann mit einem
austausch darüber rollen
und jetzt fängt der spaßige teil an ich
will mir einen muffin und stechen in der
mitte ein loch aus dann tu ich zwei bis
drei erdnüsse hinein und daran spritze
ich dann die manchmal auffüllung das
erdnussbutter frosting habe ich in einen
spritzbeutel ohne tülle um gefüllt mit
einer einfachen runden öffnung damit
spritze ich jetzt einen großen runden
kreis auf und decke ihn dann rundherum
mit den gemahlenen erdnüssen ein dass
seine frosting gebe ich dann mit einer
rosen tolle drauf ich habe jetzt hier
die 1 mm tele von wilden
jetzt kann man das ganze noch mit
karamellsoße erdnüssen und klein
sneakers stückchen verzieren
die cupcakes super lecker und haben
dieses besondere wenn sich auf süß
trifft man sollte sie aber auf jeden
fall im kühlschrank lagern und 20
minuten vor dem verzehr rausholen
viel spaß beim nachbacken bis zum
nächsten mal bei k s kitchen